dr. storm we gave you six years and
millions of dollars and you gave us
nothing what's different now Reed
Richards he Wells answers to questions
we don't even know the last gift this is
our chance to learn more about our
planet and maybe even save it I watch it
it meets my daughter's suit you want to
be famous
I just want my work to make a difference
John Green this guy doesn't take orders
well yeah especially for people who say
I don't take orders well don't let any
of these lab coats give you any crap I
well if I do I know who to call the
muscle I gotta say it's fun having you
here really mm-hmm what you've created
here is incredible
[Music]
you guys sure you're in the best shape
to be doing this yeah we're good they
just cracked interdimensional travel
all I want to know is where are my
children for ad survive all exhibit
unique physical conditions
just wouldn't fix my friends you can't
fix this you should use these powers to
help people
you open the door you don't know how to
close you don't know anything about
what's going
but who's coming
if you want to stop him
it's gonna take everything you have
how long until he's in two minutes
might be a little list